this is my team so I'm coaching I know
I'm GM so I don't have I'm not played
I came playing B to GM at the same time
I'm Emma Smith I meter girls my toes
this is any Testaverde I'm Tony Gonzalez
I'm Laura sky I'm Erin Donna here with
bleach report to build my all-time super
bullet engine I gotta get Tom Brady Tom
Brady I'm gonna go with Tom Tom Brady
Brady you want 60 mostly you know you
gonna find a way to win okay well you
always got to start with a quarterback
so I'm going to start with Joe Montana
ah then from there we'll go with the
running backs I'm gonna take Barry
Sanders loved watching him if I was a
tecmo bowl guy - when you got Barry
Sanders playing Tecmo Bowl you couldn't
be tackling he was a guy running back
Jim Brown you can even ask the greatest
of the great running back so they'll all
tell you Jim Brown was the best to ever
play at his position you'll need to run
the bet I got Randy I got well and I got
Reggie hey you told air to go run the
ball bet you'll go around the ball well
I'm a I'm I'm gonna go him I'm gonna go
Tony Gonzalez I think it'd be silly not
to pick myself I was pretty good for a
while I'm gonna get robbed and nobody
got robbed wide receiver at the door
Randy Moss I'd love to have had than any
of my team to throw do you go with Randy
because it's Randy you don't tell me
anytime you ever caught the ball you
didn't say Randy all right
I thought to say Jerry Rice can't go
Junior I see this up he's consistent you
know he go Gaeta say he going dumb and
every single time similar same way I'm
gonna go hook Lawrence Taylor come on
Lawrence Taylor let's go out there like
a bunch of crazed dogs and have some fun
you remember him saying that because
they say defense wins championships
right so with that said I'm going
defense the end
Reggie White and Bruce Smith we're
coming at the quarterback at prime time
it was at a prime time and hey read for
me return it to both of them but you
know prime time we did some stuff crazy
white ain't much to say that you don't
know about them the man had a hump move
that was unbelievable
was dominate with two different
organizations like I said we got his
number retired two different
organizations if you can find someone
who can stop Rob Gronkowski or Lawrence
Taylor you know I pay you the squad
right here I'm pretty pretty proud of
this I think I picked a good squad and I
think them guys are who it is so so with
all these all these five people right
now IV a with multiple championships
that's on coaching and on playing yeah
Lee I know